[Music]
welcome you here this afternoon and to
introduce the second of this year's
Killian award lectures last week I took
a few moments to make some remarks about
the award demand for whom it's named and
about the current recipient and those of
you who may have missed those will have
to look on last week's videotape because
I don't intend to repeat them today let
me just again briefly acknowledge the
presence of dr. James Killian here the
man for whom this award is named and and
in whose name it is given and with that
I look upon my function largely to fill
the few seconds it takes for you to
quiet down in your seat and then to
introduce the speaker today Phil
Morrison who will turn on the fireworks
Thank You dr. Killian and friends last
week I indulged in a rather complex
structure of talk which contains some
account of public illusions some account
of the dreams and hopes of the
physicists and some of the problem of
Education which might hope to bring
these things together so it was a kind
of dance of ideas and it could exhaust
none of them this afternoon I'm going to
give a much more focused talk will still
be very much Cavalier dismissal of a
very large and important subject simply
on grounds of time and preparation I
think it's an appropriate one you it
just occurred to me sitting here that
the time during which these notions have
principally developed of course they
rest upon a very old foundation Leigha
principally developed since essentially
the very year that I came as a faculty
member to MIT more than 20 years ago and
most of what I will do this afternoon is
to make a very broad brush account of
the progress of the astronomy a very
deep space galactic astronomy not on the
one hand the cosmology of the universe
as a whole to which I said about which I
said something last time nor on the
other hand the exciting discoveries
about matters closer at hand for the
stars and the planets on the contrary
it's that middle range it's quite a deep
range which I shall address because here
we have come into what I think is a can
be described in a very interesting and
simple way which makes some essential
points about understanding and our lack
of understanding without much regard to
the great detail
I should hesitate to talk without
beginning by saying that most of what I
have to say is based on the results of
experimenters what you know
remember to calm observers but really
experimenters who are provided with
equipment and with understanding of what
it means and how to use it by physics it
comes out of physics it is the physics
applied to astronomy the theoretical
ideas which these and induce in us and
the explanations we give are so partial
and immature as highly to be worth
designating with the word theory and
you'll see throughout that it is
primarily we are led by what we see and
we cobble up some kind of explanation to
try to make sense of it given the strong
understanding we have of the principle
nature of forces and matter that we can
deal with in the laboratory this is
quite distinct from the other great
frontier of particle physics because
there are so much beautiful detail is
known and there the system is
intrinsically as we believe simple and
elegant can be described by a few
mathematical formulations and an
algebraic group or two can be found
which will say a great deal about these
but in the domain of the large which
you're here engaging that doesn't seem
to be true at all the variety of
possibilities that lie in implicit in
the physics is very great and which one
has been turned on by the circumstances
of their origin is more than we can
imagine
until we see it because you can do them
almost anything shuffling the cards
dealt by Newton and Einstein by by Al
vane and Dirac as you will and these are
what we see so I shall have to say that
here observation and experiment far lead
theory and prediction and the
over-enthusiastic notion of doing
experiments to test discriminate between
hypotheses is very hard to come by and
astronomy and generally doesn't work it
turns out the third leg of the fork is
what you wanted the third time of the
fork and neither are the ones you were
discriminating and what we primarily
have have done is explore but this
expression is very excited
it's not without its rationale and I
shall try to point that out but that's
really what what is involved I'm hoping
to leave you with a an overall view of
very strange circumstances which I think
are as they might be hoped to be
significant for everyone entirely apart
from the details as part of our
understanding of the world in which we
in which we are now I'm going to begin
with a picture so if we get over the
first slide I think that would be very
nice and then we'll follow with a few
slides rather quickly in between I might
turn on some of these notes to make some
sense of it now I hope you can see this
slide maybe for this winter's rather
faint though we could kill off at least
one of those lights can you see that
slide it's supposed to evoke I hope you
can see the reddish color at the horizon
and the excellent and the sky
thank you it's supposed to evoke a
sunset and in that sunset which stands
and will stand and I will close the
slide something like this will stand
throughout for that kind of warming HUF
by which our life is is made here on
earth that is to say the light of hours
of the star the Sun to which to some
degree we belong we dwell in this hearth
we are nurtured by that sunshine as the
earth has been it's curious fabric of
living matter for pushing for billion
years and billions of years yet to come
but there's something else of course in
that picture it's not only a sunset
it's a sunset which mocks a line the
line is not drawn but the line can be
evoked there these three objects and the
Sun which of course the horns of the
Moon point the bow is being drawn by
Diana aiming at the Sun just below the
horizon here somewhere
so you see four points make a straight
line well I know us on a very straight
line but it's good enough for astronomy
it is of course indeed rather a nice
straight line in some ways it's the
marks a cut through what we call the
plane of the ecliptic and the greatest
common place by where it's delightful to
see and can be seen in clear weather all
the time now at sunset at least a little
bit whenever the moon is in toward a new
phase because Venus has been
conveniently there and mercury and from
time to time even Mars so don't miss
looking for this order if you haven't
seen it frequently but now let me go to
another example and the next slide shows
a very different straight line I think
you recognize it again this is kind of a
blurry picture of woods around the
camera and this is a wide-angle camera
view emphasizing the Milky Way with its
curdled and dusty looking appearance
going across the side another straight
line very interesting and next I
deliberately chose this these two
pictures to be about the same
orientation they're looking at about the
same direction and abs in space with
respect to earth and Sun and this
however of course is a map it is not a
photograph it is a computer-generated
color-coded map of the observations made
by wonderful satellite a year ago the
iris satellite looking at the same
direction from orbit with its cryogenic
infrared I looking at the center of the
galaxy which is in there and it has
something like the same scale this is a
big swath of the sky and across that
swath of sky goes this wonderful
straight ribbon and the color coding
just tells you different intensities
different wavelengths the infrared not
relevant to my purpose at the moment you
can simply say that there is a layer
which is able to emit lots of infrared
dominating the sky brightness and that
layer is a flat disc and of course the
other flat disc is the layer of the
planets of the solar system when you cut
it either way you see just a line and of
course that's the typical situation now
this is a much better view than we got
with a milky way from Earth because you
don't see very far you're not seeing a
depth you're seeing only the nearby
stuff that
to hang in that flat disc and of course
nearby its size box large and justice in
the way but infrared is penetrating it
goes right through the galaxy and it
gives you a view of the distance center
with no great problems at all and you
see again how flat and the the disc or
if you like how straight the
cross-section the disc as we look there
and I think that would be no I think one
more slide at this point is worthwhile
making I want to add just one more
element those really should I think I'll
wait rights I'll come to the next one
now what I've said so far is simply that
we live in what I would like to call
gosh I'd like to call that a horse we
live in the hearth in front of the
hearth which is the Sun of course we
have grown to live there we couldn't
live anywhere else really not very well
and so it's no wonder we are superbly
fitted to that environment by a long
process which is not my purpose to under
to describe now I would like to go a
little bit from these broad observations
which I think justify what I'm saying to
try to induce little physics I must do
that the physics I will take is really
drawn from the laboratory of course it
requires a lot of maturity and I shall
simply skip that I'll simply assert it
and I believe most everyone will know
what I'm saying
and feel that it is probably right but I
could of course demonstrate it similarly
interesting leaf in the lab but I'd
rather say this is what the fear is no
as a result of laboratory experience
what are the forces that we look at
whose work we look at we look far away
out into the universe even as far as the
planets even indeed as far as our own
lives if we drop a ball or walk upstairs
we're engaged as we know with
interaction with the earth as a whole
the gravitational force that was
recognized
and characterized by Newton now why is
gravitation the dominant force we're
going to consider it it's negligible in
the laboratory no protons practically
have ever heard of gravitation in the in
the accelerators they can hardly be
expected to bulk matter yes it knows it
very well but individual particles
hardly at all around here now of course
the answer is quite clear and I simply
want to emphasize everything knows this
but I just bring it forward it's the
basis of all I'm going to say
gravitation is an insatiable force it's
unstable it wants to grow at the expense
of its environment any gravitating
center of course we know that the
gravitational force is proportional to
the product of the two masses that are
engaged that's the familiar formula from
elementary physics m1 m2 over R squared
and so on and of course if I imagine
that I satisfy the force and let some
matter fall in as attracted what happens
to the force center why it is reinforced
it has extra mass and so it grows and in
this sense it's insatiable the
physicists say cannot be saturated which
is just another way of saying the same
thing on the other hand if we have
electromagnetic forces which as everyone
knows are intensely stronger particle by
particle for example in the atom I
Blanche to use the number in the atom
there are ten to thirty eight times
stronger than the gravitational forces
we can electron and proton so it's you
know no contest and on the other hand
they have an extraordinary property they
are not insatiable in fact they saturate
at once for two reasons firstly as a
nation of the force a second has a
quantized nature of charge which comes
in such limited numbers it's just plus
one and minus one and that's it and none
I suppose and the plus minus cancel so
if I have a positive charge which
attracts unlike charges and draws in a
positive charge in a negative charge
down the potential slope of course it
gets a little negative but since it was
positive it getting a little more
negative it's not as strong as it used
to be if it gains again it will look and
in the end it has nothing and so if you
pile up matter unless you're extremely
powerful when you pile up a lot
matter it will have no important
electrostatic force left though a big
gravitational force left because the
plus and minuses will cancel but the
tiny gravitation never cancels it's
always augmented and of course that is
the reason why the universe is dominated
by gravitational forces since it
consists of very large pieces of matter
from our point of view this is always
spoken from our equals zero our Center
our position now I will say however that
in the if you have electromagnetic
forces in the broad depths of space
which you are examining you should
remember also that the current which is
present whatever matter is present can
be present whatever matter is present
and we'll see especially true in the
highly charged highly ionized domain of
space
if currents move they tend to short out
electrical fields that's just the
argument I made they move towards down
the field and cancel when they get there
on the other hand those very same
currents nourish the B field the
magnetic field because it is current
that makes B field and not charged so
even if I have equal and opposite
charges moving in equal and opposite
directions cancels out charge
wonderfully but only augments the B
field splendidly
so the B field indeed is the only part
left mechanism we will see we have
perhaps the most interesting arguments
of the not the last twenty years in the
20 years before that in all of deep
space astronomy where the the
demonstration there were indeed my
extensive magnetic fields in space and I
shall draw upon that later
so that's what the forces are and now if
you want forces on charges if there's no
electric field then the forces are
gravitational which are small or if you
have individual particles and a B field
is moving by you can take advantage
broadly speaking of what is called the
Lorentz force the velocity dependent
force V cross B which works on a charge
and the physicists will know right away
that that's what goes on behind the
motion of individual charges should we
ever see such things in the course of
our studies now it is appropriate having
discussed the forces also to mention the
forms and here I think I already given
the forms and I would
just uncover the discussion that I want
of the forms that means geometrical
forms under which these forces exist in
in space this is a very old and
long-established proposition the first
form of course is the sphere and the
sphere because it has no orientation is
a sign that random motion is there
struggling against isotropic everywhere
that every direction the same
gravitation gravitation is a central
force it draws toward the center the Sun
draws its planets the earth draws
everything on its surface and that
bodies are beautifully spherical and the
moon in the first picture was spherical
only half illuminated by the Sun quarter
illuminated as you saw and you know very
well this is the phenomenon that all the
objects that officially large and thus
dominated by gravitational forces are in
fact serrocold all the nearby objects
now there is of course something to be
said against that it's very nice to have
this by the way the random motion in the
case of in the case of the Sun we know
it's the gas pressure of the hot gases
within the Sun very reasonable and we'll
see other examples the what I call away
will now call and tend to call the disk
that is the flat plane in which the
planets move and in which the galaxy's
material seems to be gathered
preferentially together that disk is a
two dimensional motion the planets orbit
they do not whiz up-and-down the axial
velocity has disappeared and this must
be a historical thing and now you see we
come into the problem of history which
will dominate this entire first
discussion because why should they not
have motions in all directions
well we begin to see now we can see that
if you have a system such that it can
lose axial motion it will not fall in by
that virtue because it is only the
motion in the plane at right angles to
the axis going through the revolution an
axis that keeps the thing in place so if
you don't lose that you'll still stay in
place yet you will change from the
three dimensional randomness to a
two-dimensional flat plane a phenomenon
which seems quite important since it
dominates at many scales already we've
seen that dominates the solar system's
planets the orbits and it dominates the
orbits of the stars that make up and
dust that make up the vast plane of the
Milky Way and very striking that that
should be seen and these two forms
sphere and disc then acquire their
realism from this argument and to go a
little further into mechanics I will say
all right here's a meant to be around in
the sphere and I can characterize that
random sphere in a very nice way by
using what all students of mechanics
were recognized as the virial theorem
I just don't worry about the name a
final Latinate name the kinetic energy
is about equal to the potential energy
for any system held together by
gravitation that is in the steady state
and that's what we find so if you have a
lot of particles moving about they
better have as much kinetic energy as
their gravitational attraction and if
they do they'll be able to withstand
otherwise they'll collapse or blow up
new one way or the other so steady state
is going to require that and this of
course is in a way you could say this is
why the Sun is hot or if you like you
can say that because the Sun is hot it
must be bound by a certain amount of
gravitational force and that fear of
course is very large and that makes us
unvaried and this is the way that the
gravity is fought by random undirected
motions you see gravity being insatiable
must be or otherwise all would
collapse to a single point somewhere and
what has what has beaten that back is in
every case some kind of motion perhaps
not so on the very very lowest level of
size where perhaps actual repulsive
forces might exist but barring that
small exception it is really motion
motion in the Sun which is gas pressure
motion in the galaxies which is the
orbiting stars and motion in the solar
system the orbiting planets and in every
case it is motion that inhibits gravity
there is no such thing as a shape which
is
not connected with motion oh how you say
the earth itself is a sphere and I've
suppressed that but of course everyone
recognizes the earth is kept up by the
forces in solid matter and those forces
indeed are also primarily random
pressure not however due to the thermal
motion so much as to the repulsive
effect of the overlapping electron
clouds and atoms that prevent matter
from collapsing onto itself
I shan't discuss that very much but this
often called a Fermi or shredding or
pressure which does the same job in any
case that's what it is I mention driver
one other important point there is we
know in mechanic's of course the energy
as a constant of the motion
we know the annual minimum as a constant
emotion a vector constant rather more
complicated and it's plain that it is
keeping J that requires these particles
to stay in this plane they don't fall in
because they have would have to lose I
canna momentum to do so it's very hard
for them to do that it's much easier to
lose energy than to lose any momentum
indeed it turns out that this is these
the properties I've described they're
puppies of the gas and such many many
interacting particles and perhaps that
also is the will be the origin of this
form both in the galaxies and in the
solar system
I don't oppress that too strongly now
the next thing I would like to describe
because I must have a background for
pictures I'm going to show you are the
substances of which the world is made
now above all the world is made of
hydrogen gas wherever we look that's
what we see this goes back it was first
brought forward in a brilliant PhD
thesis in 1925 by Cecilia Payne then a
graduate student at Harvard College
Observatory and this perhaps the most
brilliant of all astronomy PhD theses
she concluded that the world indeed she
had the Sun and the stars in mind were
made of about 90% hydrogen and
cautiously she and her adviser added
well perhaps there's something wrong
with the series that seems so incredible
but that's what the calculations suggest
of course by now it's been enormous Lee
confirmed and we know that all that we
see in fact is made of hydrogen hydrogen
has many different forms I mention them
there's even another one I didn't
mention was being too complicated
hydrogen metal let's let it go we have
h2 molecular hydrogen very significantly
Galaxy H neutral atoms of hydrogen also
quite significantly alexei and separated
hydrogen atoms II - P + drifting about
which we might call hydrogen plasma or
ionized hydrogen also quite significant
we'll see a great deal of it now I want
to point out of course that gas is lust
see gas loses energy doesn't keep it it
radiates in general turns it into
photons and emits the photons this is
how we can do astronomy anyhow but of
course this law see this is very
characteristic of guess that's not true
of the Earth's orbital motion for
example it's been going around for a
long long time and while in principle it
can radiate away its motional energy not
by charge which it has nothing of but by
mass which it has by gravitational
radiation to do so take something like
10 to the 25 years time so long that we
can leave it out of all considerations
of our present kind because
gravitational forces are so weak that
the radiation they enforce from moving
matter is so small that it's entirely
negligible as long as you deal with
simple circumstances like the one I'm
talking with Sun now the second proposal
is the rock of the earth of course and
of the terrestrial planets and I hear
I've written down as an astronomical
sign rock broken into small bits which
is what we call dust and dust and dust
which is rock dust
I shan't describe whether it's silica
what it is it's some element not
hydrogen that's what I'm really saying
by this and it has many possibilities
now I think the slide be worthwhile the
one that I cut off just look at quickly
this wonderful star field in the
southern hemisphere a beautiful
photograph for the Australians is
blurred by this object here and in the
old days it was possible still to
believe absent much mature consideration
and lots of Statistics that you were
looking here as her show himself wrote
about a similar object at a hole in
heaven walk in Himmel the star to get
out of the way and show you a beautiful
tunnel out into depths depths of space
of course that's not at all true if you
think about the statistics of it you
will see it's very unlikely so many dark
fingers are pointing in us he saw just
one maybe but if you see hundreds of
them then you have to have very bad
ideas of reference to think that the
heaven is making all these dark fingers
pointing at us or else a very bad
conscience any case we know that's not
it by looking at the light comes through
and by looking in many other ways we
know this is just a dust bank which gets
in the way and behind it there wonderful
field of stars is blanked out and all
you see are the stars that are in front
of the dust bank and that's only rather
few because it's rather close to us so
dust is an important obvious
consideration now and we say obvious but
in nineteen thirties if so it was not so
clear but now we have unmistakable
evidence for in many different ways and
we know that is really there so we have
a hydrogen a little bit of dust I want
to mention it because you'll see it over
and over again it's just the same
completeness and the third filling of
course which is which is very
interesting I shall spend a little time
talking about the third thing is an is a
construct which you won't find in the
laboratory at all because I call it star
fluid so the third element that I want
to talk about is star fluid now what is
star fluid star fluid is obviously just
kind of a metaphorical name for
something you see from a big distance
and don't see very well because star
flew is a fluid whose atoms and
particles are stellar and not atomic
that's the way it looks when you see a
picture of a galaxy let's look at a
picture of the galaxy slide please
there you see a beautiful spheres
our fluid now we see we know by sampling
there are sort of a billion such objects
we know tens of thousands of them with
some degree of detail by actually having
studied into the individually and they
represent of course something like the
Milky Way here are a couple little
outliers that's a nice big spherical one
the same one I showed last time by the
way and the next slide a more familiar
one a spiral galaxy instead of a
globular galaxy I chose this one to show
both kinds are present and again you see
right away the same theme a sphere and a
disc in this case the disc which happens
have a small sphere inside it that's
alright combination not too bad and
again the same situation we must have
random forces opposing gravitation of
pool in the symmetrical situation we
must have somehow a system that has lost
some hanging room has tried to keep it
on you atom and lost energy and has made
a disk and the two symmetries the discs
in the sphere correspond to everything
galaxies are either spheres or discs or
both
just as the solar system as a sphere a
star many little spheres running around
and they're organized in a disc it all
looks so simple that you know it gets
almost I wouldn't say dull but a little
familiar so alright I want to show
something else to show this not quite as
quick that was a bit fast you come back
to the previous picture I'd like to talk
about it for a moment there it is again
now this looks very bland but one reason
it's bland is it cuz the instruments in
which everything depends right there's
no way to get knowledge except through
the instruments every instrument makes
illusions and these expert who handles
it knows the illusions but when you look
at it hastily you might miss it many
theorists miss it for a long time doctor
it's been a long time getting this
lovely outside tracery just right by
long exposures right to bring out this
faint stuff why on the outside with all
that interesting intricate material but
will you do that you burn out the middle
it's flat and bland now a little spot no
bigger than not as big as the red light
that I put there the laser spot right in
the very middle is showing the next
slide a very short exposure and there it
is that's the bright nucleus the
Andromeda galaxy now there's nothing
predicting
about it if I take a lot of exposure I
get a bigger thing and longer is still
bigger and bigger and bigger what I want
to point out is the stars are heaped up
toward the Sun of the galaxy with a
remarkable rate of rise so the density
of stars and of star light from this
Center is three or four orders of
magnitude greater than the Stars piled
together in the same small volume
outside of course the volume which this
occurs is very small so the total
contribution of light of the of the
object is not large but compared per
unit volume it is ten thousand times
more dense and of course you know the
absence of dynamic range that means
ability to get dim you knew endo and
crescendo in the same passage that most
instruments lack that I'll show you some
later that don't lack it and you'll see
what wonderful things what's the dynamic
range brings you because you can't
always neglect faint things small things
may be quite significant in this case
the small the high intensity of that is
quite significant for us now the next
slide just to show you these things are
not always separate here I've pictured
the Coma Cluster the certain point in
space rather far away from us a couple
are a million light years you see
there's a sort of an ellipsoidal galaxy
and a few more and then there's a
edge-on spiral and there's a nice
spherical looking one and some funny
ones bunches and bunches of galaxies in
the whole in a single picture you can
count a couple thousand a couple of
hundred in that cluster with no trouble
at all so these things do occur they
cluster the galaxies are present this is
all the classical material of the
Astronomy techsoup's sometime ago now I
would like to add though what I was
saying that you see this this stuff that
I'm talking about I should give a name
to that I observe it as a you know as a
homogeneous material in these pictures
that isn't the only way to see it but
it's star stuff right its fluids it's a
fluid made of stars its form as whereas
most conspicuous in this kind of picture
of course I can with a spectrograph
examine the light in detail and of
course I can map it and see how the
density changes and so on as I've shown
you so we do have a little more
information but primarily we're studying
what I'd like to call star fluid it's
really good to call it that because
though it's made of individual stars and
those stars I'm not touching
each other we see them as though they
filled all space that's because the
instrument is not capable of separating
them instant including the atmosphere is
not capable of separating they run
together you get a glow the glow is
actually the sudden light of ten or a
hundred billion stars no one of which is
close to the other no one of which
practically hides the other either
they're so far apart by comparison their
own size like the stars in our
neighborhood but you see them merge
together and the instrument just makes a
star fluid of it so it is a star fluid
and it's worthwhile mentioning it it's
quite important so I will say the star
fluid lights can go on now the star
fluid is there the star fluid moves
about it is what made heaps up into a
sphere in the storico galaxy and is
flattened out into a disk in the disk
galaxies and maybe a sphere in the
middle it is lossless the Stars haven't
got any way of getting rid of their
emotional energy of course the
individual stars can get cooler or
warmer whatever they're doing on their
own individually and I observe that that
belongs to stellar astronomy should not
really describe very interesting and
almost mature between 1920 and 1970
roughly speaking that was the time which
we understood most not everything
most of what stars do so this lossless
fluid its lossless in its motions it has
no way it doesn't collide it doesn't
bump into and do it those stars move
into each other they don't the friction
they have from the residual gas which
might be present is very small can you
stop a star with just the friction of
gas you can't do it and so it is a kind
of perpetual flow of fluid a very nice
thing to study how dramatically of
course don't forget two things first
it's interactive
though it is lossless is by no means
inert because it is attracted to
attracts gravitationally with great
vigor we're talking about little parcels
of fluid flowing about each one is 10
million stars in it it's not a small
concept lots of energy there lots of
gravitational attraction but of course
it can't evaporate it can dissipate and
if it's thrown out into space and may
very dilute we don't see it because we
can't see just a tiny bit of light
against the background of everything
else so you have to have it less than
dilute in order to see it so that's the
third material
but now in terms of that material and
the two things I've described namely the
hydrogen dust and star fluid we have a
description of all that we can see in
galaxies and the solar system solar
system is the is the prototype and then
in the galaxies world which I'm talking
about
the galaxy does the same thing discs and
spheres and their combinations clearly a
balance of energy and angular momentum
the great constants of mechanics the
star fluid flowing about and adjusting
itself in to fight the gravitation
either with spherical random motions or
with well oriented circular motions or
quasi circular motions and of course
there are lots of small differences
there
the famous density waves and make the
spirals and professor Lin and so on but
these are from this broad brush portrait
they are details very interesting and
significant for origins perhaps but not
determining the broad picture I haven't
had to show you pictures of those which
was very conspicuous so I can say that
the solar system in the galaxies ruled
by gravitation as we admit made of
hydrogen of course the hydrogen makes up
the stars too but we're not talking
about the stars except as parts of the
fluid and a little dust thrown around to
make the earth in the dust of space
solar system in the galaxies ruled by
gravitation seemed as tranquil as the
Almanac the rounds of their heavens
while quite interesting and the
gyrations are fun for us to watch and
study and we can time ourselves and
navigate and do wonderful things it is
really the Almanac you look it up and
there's just what it will be it's
already out for 1989 I believe and it's
going to be right you won't find any
errors and that's about all you could
that's the only part of the subject
which has that quality I can assure you
and of course that quality enormous Lee
misled us until we got better
instrumentation and better understanding
this is home home is where the hard
floor how it is and home is where you
get your wrong ideas
okay so now we'll talk about it 20 years
is brought mostly because you could have
the ability to look rather far away
because if you may well believe home is
where the heart is that's it's not a
coincidence yes here I must invoke the
fact that if it were not that way it's
very hard to make a living you can only
work when the Sun rises every day or at
least on weekdays and things like that
so you've got to have a general
regularity are there irregularities
disorder chaos lack of equilibrium lack
of clear temperatures discs and spheres
are there those things the solar system
you bet they are cosmic rays aurora
borealis comets meteorites asteroids but
you know you got to be an expert to know
about them well perhaps you can see a
comet from time to time and the ancients
were right to feel the comet was a sign
that things are going wrong because the
comet I have only to point out one
remark comets of course they're not very
bright but comets are not in the
ecliptic plane in fact they're uniformly
distributed in direction so how come we
had a good argument well you know it
shows that details if pursued will lead
you far away and so we didn't we weren't
wholly deceived but broadly speaking we
had the illusion that gravitation is a
delicate subject which works on fine
details and you can get yes the the
precession of mercury was a little ahead
and so Einstein could make a great thing
of that that's the kind of style it was
and so that's the way we did the thing
for a long time but that was once and
it's not any longer
now I say we come to the fireworks it
turns out that this entire picture is
based on experience common sense the
common sense of the scientists engage in
galactic and planetary observations but
it's wrong I should not say it's wrong
it's not a blunder it's incomplete and
that's of course generally what we have
we have well-founded theories well our
descriptions that don't cover all
circumstances they cover our
circumstances
the time and that's why they fit and
when you press the limits you find
something new happening so I come in and
it will turn out that I get to introduce
real early one more new substance it
isn't substance it's novel its motion
and form and we'll come to that as it
goes on in the first place I think we
should look at a slide or two if
galaxies cluster they come close
together when galaxies come close
together they sometimes approach each
other and confront each other in this
interesting way this is a square dancing
pair of galaxies and it bears tales I
mean gosh that doesn't make anything you
ever saw in the typical book of some
years ago it was there all the time
but it was only one hundred ten thousand
so who's going to bother to pick up such
an anomaly and now we understand a
little better and the second picture
this one is called the ant any for
obvious reasons and here the galaxies
are flinging something over each other's
shoulder in a strange way this has been
beautifully modeled by our to Murray
here for the past 15 years or so in
simulated effect and there's no question
to what we're seeing and I will describe
it in the following language you know by
direct observation that the motion in
those twigs those branches that come out
is not a anomalous or strange motion it
is a motion rather like the rest but the
form is very strange what has happened
is that the tidal flow has drawn out
star field star fluid which also can
recoil gravitationally just as the tidal
bulge recoils from the moon if you know
there are two bulges of the tide zone on
the earth and drags with the gas and if
galaxies will but collide with each
other that has come near each other then
this beautifully stabilized sphere disk
fluid that we talked about which has no
losses and responds beautifully to any
pool upon it gives up its allegiance to
that beautiful order which was all
historical no longer has zero mmm
z regular and perhaps it has the right
coming around with respect to its own
center but now conflicting center has
entered what to do it has now a lot
allowing you in respect to that one it
makes some kind of a balance that a
complicated thing in the shoes which I
shall describe but has been worked out
in beautiful detail by a computer
simulation and to some extent by
analysis and in these collisions we are
quite clear that the star fluid is drawn
out
it's just stars with accompanying gas
nothing bizarre but drawn out into tails
and even rings and mergers and the next
slides will show you what some of these
things might look like there this is in
the sky this is not something in the
computer it's a bad photograph or a
rather remote galaxy but it's a funny
one it's a ring blobby ring right I mean
looks like some I suppose some piece of
pressed pasta you might get like that
like alphabet soup well look at the next
slide which was a computer simulation of
two Marie and coworkers I'm like this
one suppose you have a model galaxy just
stars moving around in Nice circular
rings around an axis and I fling through
that axis right down there and another
galaxy small but rather massive similar
and mass to this whole disk and watch
what it does it induces a beautiful
central ring they've put it weekly it
induces an off-center ring like though
matching the one we have and it does so
rather straightforward way just by
gravitational forces gravitational
forces draw the particles in and then as
it goes away they come out again and in
all this dough seed owing they run for a
while in the same positions it turns out
that they their positions cross each
other as they're trying to get in and
out and therefore transiently during
this event they make a ring which will
dissolve a rather short time on galactic
scale a time small compared to the time
the gaussian turn around once maybe a
half or a third of that time so you see
right away and now we have maybe 50 or a
hundred of these objects of all all
these kinds the next kind will show
another one here's a galatin so very
normal looking you look two Kilgallen
it's it's just it's a flat galaxy s 0
so-called doesn't every spiral arms or
gas in it but it's a rotating disk and
the spectral lines show you its rotation
and then lo and behold it has a ring the
other way I mean that's not
self-respecting when I was when I was
brought up to learning this subject very
badly in a particular course in
astronomy I would have thought it
outlandish that I have a thing like a
solar system but that instead of the
solar system and everything the ecliptic
plane and that even I could imagine
there's a sphere of comets that flies in
from all directions but to have a ring
going through the pole and around
belongs in a library it doesn't belong
in the sky I mean it's the ring that
holds the globe of the earth right well
I mean there you have it there you have
it and it's real and it's made of bright
stars and it's not moving especially
rapidly it's moving just the way it has
to move to be in that condition it's
highly transient as you may well imagine
it will spin around in its own plane and
gradually work its way until it's merged
into the disk very likely in the course
of some time but transiently we see them
so there's a lot of fireworks of this
strange motional form kind of found in
the galaxies here's not a picture in
which people overexposed heavily they
lose the ring but to bring out all this
gas all these stars which have come out
of a gas that's been made somehow
everyone believes I think it's right the
collision has occurred in the past and
some Gauss ease of merged and the
consequences to fill up this polar
region with some gas in which some star
is condensed and now we see this object
for a while in this bedecked fashion
galaxies in short do not have single
origins they are what the biologists
call polyphyletic they have more than
one ancestor very often and of course
untangling their origins in ignorant of
that is going to give you a very hard
time maybe simple galaxies well only one
else is good we'll look for those but
that's not all there is and so don't be
worried about anomalies the world is
various and this what we see so I say
the common conflict of you get tight
tails and rings I think I should have
the other one too
sorry there's one more bad slide but
worth looking at this is a galaxy and
it's got the measles it's all one galaxy
but it seems they have many centrioles
hotspots central nuclei and the general
view is we
looking here at a Talib cannibal galaxy
some saturn Chronos who has eaten his
own children and there they are half
digested in the stomach of the beast
whizzing around him there I don't know
if this interpretation was full fully
there are five it looks pretty good and
there's no question that is happening
the galaxies merged you say how can it
be if it's lossless that you can get
caught well you see how it can be very
well it's not that it's that the energy
is lost to the star system no no it's
gay that's remains but it's given some
energy to stars that have flown away and
therefore taking some energy from stars
that remain behind and they're orbiting
around while the rest was sprayed out
into space over low energy is not lost
there's no collision in the sense that
there's not much radiation excitement
sound nothing of that sort just a
removing of the star fluid because star
fluid has only those properties it's
quite a remarkable result and a
describing it gives us an account of
about Oh a large fraction of all the
galaxies were published say many years
ago in a wonderful iconoclastic paper
book by by Chip ARP which he called
peculiar galaxies he's a specialist in
mustering anomalies he mustered up all
the anomalous galaxies he could take
pictures of and good half of his
galaxies perhaps belong to this
collisional stuff where star fluid was
worked into funny shapes just because of
collisions and the aftermath of
collisions always under gravitational
force now I want to say a little bit
about scale because that enables to make
the next the next jump scale tells us
this this is the next kind of fireworks
a kilowatt hour everybody knows the
kilowatt for an hour one kilowatt hour a
Sun Life is another you know some power
for one solar lifetime not our lifetime
solar lifetime
that's another unit of energy just like
the kilowatt hour the Sun life it's a
lot of energy it's the kind I just give
it out in one supernova all at once and
if in a few months time it's about ten
to the tenth solar years and this is the
scale of what stars can do
it's about all stars can do now a lot of
events that we see in the what we saw
here there might be
stars and supernovae nothing much just
star first are giving out its its Sun
life power would be plenty to account
for all the things we see in these
relatively tame but badly disturbed
forms but that's not all we see the next
thing we see is shown in the in the next
slide - very nice galaxies rather nearby
and in the constellation Ursa Major in
that direction known to everybody is m81
m82 like to point out this shy one here
there's another one
it's called 307 sevens not my fault it
photographer didn't adjust the field
very well to get that but there are
three are there and there's even a
fourth one down off this corner just
very unpleasant the way that the
photographs are taken the next slide
will show you something a little
different now this is the same field in
the sky some map you recognize I would
no longer photograph and I've drawn the
plus for this the plus sign is the
Galaxy itself that's there may be one
that beautiful big one it was in the
center 272 little went up there in the
corner this is the one that was shyly
over the edge and this is one you didn't
see it also on the edge even in this
picture now what is this map this map is
a wonderful map made by the radio
astronomers of course it is only because
we have the power to look and so many
wave bands that we can make this kind of
study and this is an old picture decade
older more in which somebody has made
the radio frequency signature of this
same object and I have marked with the
plus sign where the galaxy centers are
and the optical galaxies are not much
bigger than those plus signs a couple
times bigger for the bigger one not and
so on and you see that there's a whole
mess around there and we know from the
nature of respect to a line which this
was taken that that is neutral hydrogen
gas atomic hydrogen a giant cloud of
atomic hydrogen whose motions we can see
but they're very complicated surrounds
these four galaxies that are immersed in
that cloud now this is quite a general
phenomenon we see that very often around
galaxies but we don't see multiple
galaxies immersed in a single cloud very
often these galaxies have been in
interaction they have flung out hydrogen
gas it is flowing about in there and it
completely what was an invisible part of
the universe is now clearly an important
part of the history it is not
dynamically important that's to say the
mass of the gas
is small compared to the mass of all
those galaxies not enormous Li small but
of the order one percent or a putt in a
thousand something like that so it's not
making the galaxies move rather the
galaxies are making the gas move so that
seems alright but notice what happened
to M 82 which is one that I spent quite
a few years we're worrying about which
is this fellow up there let's look at
the next picture there it is
colorfully displayed in the usual color
enhanced photograph
notice it's a very you know it's not a
galaxy you put in the textbook to
illustrate spirals it is a circular disc
rotating the usual way seemed rather
edgewise
so you've seen as a long spindle you
noticed spiral ISM is gone is full of
these dusty clouds you can't make out
any individual stars in it much all
that's entirely consistent with all the
infrared and everything else you do you
see it an infrared x-rays radio all
these work let me show you a few more
pictures same object here is the same
picture as before without the color
optical here it is looking for a clear
color of light just the hydrogen alpha
line neutral hydrogen being flung out
rather faintly from the two poles here's
the polarized light coming from a big
surround of the whole thing and more
polarized light a different polarization
direction also way out on the outside of
that spindle we've had very little doubt
that this is a very dusty galaxy dust is
filling the whole region and the dust is
concentrated towards m82 and that dust
is giving rise to polarized light that
is seen here I needn't describe why that
is that just as a useful phenomenon for
people to look at now let's look inside
the galaxy a little more closely here's
a radio picture of the insides of the
inner 10th beautiful colored contour map
and look at that fine bright large red
burning source there that's the biggest
source in m82 this is a slide due to
Kronberg toronto bond and since then not
yet published but in the last few months
professor Condor has worked on this
object for many years has made really
excellent high-resolution study at the
VLA and he would now if I had brought
his map it's too complicated to bring in
I think this same region contains four
dozen other sources like that
course all about five or ten times
fainter they don't show up in this
picture
not enough dynamic range but little
point sources filling up the whole
region so the notion that maybe this
thing was a nucleus of the galaxy you
see the suggestion Andromeda had a
nucleus which is just a collection of
stars but other galaxies will see have
nuclei there as much activity is going
on and here's a galaxy that is bright in
x-rays and IR everything else in the
center and radio but we looked at it in
detail it was not from the center it was
not from a single source it was spread
around throughout this region and so if
I have called I think this new galaxy
which is falsely active and when you
look at more detail you see that's the
case here's what the core looks like if
I map it actually with with a pen next
to this is the way the m82 looks with
various objects that people have seen IR
sources of radio sources and bright
clusters of stars and so on and through
the dust very hard to see here's our
galaxy core in the same region this is
about eight times as big as I galaxy
it's only one tenth of the one tenth of
m82 which is smaller their own galaxy
but very much larger than a little point
in the middle and that's the odd thing
I'm talking about
here's what I'll go see would look like
if it were enlarged the same scale just
enlarge it and now you see it too has
this kind of miscellaneous junky things
radio and x-ray and IR and all sorts of
wonderful things there is very little
doubt that the m82 in all its glory is
an object which has not got a single
active center inside but has instead a
collection of stars a very rich abundant
collection of newly formed stars giving
out x-rays and I are making explosions
that give radio sources doing all the
things that supernovae do and other
disturbed stars and that is indeed what
it is it is a starburst galaxy in this
galaxy within the last few hundred
million years there was started in its
centre a generation abundant rash of
stars all born more or less together and
still being borne out of the game
rushing around inside there so it's a
kind of activity but no single part of
that activity is more than the one
sunlight for 10 Sun Life kind of thing
I'm talking about it is not any great
single center that is doing it it has a
burst of stars very exciting and they're
interesting but in a way not really on a
galactic scale and there's little doubt
that what did it was that the star fluid
that appeared brought gas with it and
the gas from that radio cloud that we
saw fell into the center having been
expelled from its own galaxy and no
longer with any great legions turns on
your mind with respect to that new
center phalion and stars condensed from
that material a truly remarkable event
which is a possibility that gas can
condense in star bursts and form stars
of course it is gas that must form stars
and stars that give rise to gas and this
transaction we've known in our own
galaxy for quite some time and now we
see it as an epidemic in other galaxies
but that still is not the story of the
fireworks that we really want to tell
because these are all mild fireworks
let's instead go on to the still more
grandiose kinds of events lights here's
that same m87 galaxy but underexposed so
you don't see as big as sphere as you
did before
in color which makes it look nice and
notice this funny thing sticking out
like the tip of a hand of a clock let's
look at the next picture I'm too exposed
still wore on a complete hand of a clock
let's look at the next picture I'm too
exposed here it is again with a little
tip here it is with a hand coming out
and here it is with the so little
exposed that only the bright central
core is there and the tip of the hand is
there now we know great deal more about
this now but suffice it to say this is
an object of big size sub galactic
because it was inside m87 you didn't see
it if you burned out the center if you
look at the center you'll see it but
it's not at the center again it's a
but it is a jet as a linear structure
coming out and we see now quite a few of
nothing quite like this but quite a few
related objects and I think I'm gonna
have to say that this is a quite
characteristic thing to look for and
above all the scale is what is important
the scale by which I mean other energy
scale of such objects pushes 10 to the
8th 10 to the 10th 10 to the 12th son
lifes the x-rays gamma rays perhaps
cosmic rays other high-energy phenomena
occur there and this is the what makes
it quite interesting now the next few
slides will show the domain of the
quasars I have call these these are the
Kindred and the quasars here is the most
famous one of the brightest nearby
quasars only 3000 million light years
away and there it is heavily overexposed
as for in just a tiny spots a speck but
the telescope brings it out looking as
big as the Stars which of course are
also just spots spread by the quivery
motion of the atmosphere but notice this
jet now that jet is a we now have reason
to believe a hundred times bigger than
the jet of m87
in real life it's quite a remarkable
thing to pictures of it in two different
colors let's look at it again in the
radio there's a little road nice radio
source around the centre quasar itself
and here's this wonderful hand of a
clock affair about a hundred times
larger and now all this the optical jet
is right in here this is not this goes
well beyond the optical jet what is that
map showing that map is showing the
presence of radio emission a large
amount of it the size of it is bigger
than 100 galaxies you don't see it at
all if you don't look at the radio it is
a region of space filled
we now believe with relativistic
particles I'm going to call it
high-energy plasma we see hundreds of
examples thousands of examples so we
really believe astir it's the next
constituent I know there must be
something strange because it's scale
energy scale is enormous compared to
that of any star it's a galactic
dimensions or greater than galactic
dimensions it doesn't give any visible
light at all
very little
it gives polarized radio and the best
explanation is that it is interaction
between hydrogen ionized hydrogen plasma
relativistic energies and magnetic
fields so I'm good some novel substance
high-energy plasma and B fields the
velocity electrons is of the ordinate
velocity of light I remind you of last
electron an atom is one percent of losev
light so this is really far beyond
anything that atoms can dig up it is a
much more as we say relativistic energy
now the center of this object is worth
looking at too and here's a remarkable
picture of it there it is the plus shows
where the center of that galaxy would be
which you didn't see this is in fact a
magnification this is a galaxy this
orange stuff and this is the direction
of that jet this has taken the visible
light but enormous ly heavily doctored
so it's not a photograph at all but a
map elaborately treated by computer to
bring out this fine detail so we are
pretty sure that the quasar is a
brilliant spot a hundred or a thousand
times brighter galaxy living inside a
galaxy capable of throwing out a jet
like the one we saw in this case and the
jet at the end makes a grand pool of
relativistic plasma or high-energy
plasma as i've called it out in space a
truly remarkable explosive event
stations and a great distance apart
timing them by a absolute clock have
been able to resolve a thousand times
better than the resolution of an optical
telescope so they're looking at a
magnification deep deep in the heart of
the object far smarter think I showed in
any of the pictures before and when you
look at that magnification you see two
clouds this permanent cloud and this
moving one and that's been done now and
a dozen objects all the same kind these
brilliant quasars and radio galaxies
surrounded by great pools of
relativistic plasma and the conclusion
is hard to avoid that you're seeing the
separation of that inner cloud from the
central cloud moving with a speed as you
see written there 10 times the speed of
light this is the so-called superluminal
expansion of the cores of radio galaxies
while we know that no physical object is
moving faster than the speed of light
would be very surprised would take
powerful evidence indeed to disabuse
this in that view so we haven't been
able to figure out that it is of course
interesting the illusion just don't
really describe it depends on the fact
that you're looking at something as
approaching you very rapidly and so the
correction for the time that it takes
the light to get here must be taken into
account it's moving nearly as fast as
like toward you so that makes a big
difference the other one is not moving
toward you and that makes the difference
and if you correct for that turns out
that relativity indeed predicts exactly
that effect objects moving toward you
will appear to be moving in their small
way across the line of sight their lower
angle not exactly towards a little bit
to one side they'll appear to move in
that direction very rapidly indeed
because you don't see them with the
right time delay every part that you're
looking at comes to a different time so
the time sequence has to be recalculated
and when you do that it comes down to
the speed of light so there's no there's
no mystery about it but a grandeur which
we really have not understood this is a
powerful object and it is certainly
puzzling what goes on in the center of
it and now the I think that's enough for
that slide we know that there must be a
central engine inside such a quasar at
high efficiency we know that because the
mass that it contains is not very great
and not enough to dominate the motions
of the galaxies so we give a limit to
the mass at the same time you see the
energy that comes out of it filling up
these great clouds and pools invisible
galaxies in space super galaxies which
are not native stars at all but of
high-energy plasma completely new world
nothing really like the world comparable
in our solar system only a little bit
two flares on the Sun but now we see
them gigantic and enduring energy much
larger than the rest mass of electrons
the electrons present and the sub
galaxies mass is doing it indeed the
size of the whole thing is smaller
probably than a light day we know that
from direct measures which give some
limits and better from time variations
which out the whole thing is so small
that you can have some time variations
inside of a light day now we're mostly
talking about ten thousand light years
the characteristic size unit so it's a
tiny needlepoint speck even the magnify
pick
I showed you was 5 or 10 light years
across now you must go inside that by
another 100 thousand magnification and
you'll see the central agent of course
we don't see we can only infer it and we
have a lot of ideas but nothing very
firm about what it makes I want to show
them the best of the ideas and then
close with this very soon so the next
slide please
here is a wonderful slide that makes the
point extremely well here's a radio
galaxy again computer maps in the radio
big puff there a big puff there and a
central galaxy to push the puff out both
directions not just one direction i 273
but as you'll see more typically in both
directions enough time as the maps for
both sides to be treated that way
now this Sun was was magnified and the
long long lines shown but this
magnification is from one mega parsec
200 kiloparsecs so this is a factor of
about 20 magnification and if we magnify
once again this is only one parsec
that's the factor of a hundred thousand
and again you see this flame light thing
we lose all detail now we just barely
get something but notice this line this
line and this line between the two great
clouds which are five million three
million light years apart and this is
only three light years long over a scale
of a million this object has moved in
such a way that along one direction in
space there's always had the same
orientation it took of course several
million years to produce so for several
million years an object has been pouring
out material along one axis in space
without ever deviating now that
stability is inertial guidance that has
to be a gyroscope there's very little
other way to make it so firm and so
again we're confirming the notion the
central edge is not only a powerful
compact object of sub galactic mass and
solar system size but also it is heavily
spinning and the only thing I wish to
draw from this is one I don't want to
say what the whole structure is but the
kinetic energy of rotation for a solid
object is of course the squared on your
modem divided by the moment of inertia
mr squared now this goes up like R
squared but the kinetic energy only go
like the gravitational energy that was
the virial theorem I quoted K like you
like thee but V goes like what over R so
while K goes up as something contracts
the K rotational sure and have a
rotation goes up even faster and so
eventually it will catch up and take the
lion's share of the kinetic energy and
make what I think we have to call a
whirlpool and that indeed is the last
kind of fireworks it's the most powerful
the most extraordinary we now know of
some thousands of these objects some
well-studied some only with one hint to
their nature and they are pretty surely
all of them massive whirlpools of
spinning magnetized material whose
center is generally held to be a black
hole not in itself demonstrated yet but
we must find some mechanism for for that
to work and this is rather a plausible
their concealed by their size and by
radiation and particle attraction
they're so dense with energy in a
well-defined case they're so full of
radiation that the particles on the way
out and then photons the way out
mutually attracting each other in a
strong way as well as any magnetic
fields that are present and concealed in
this possible interaction the details of
the structure that present this is the
center of the whirlpool and of course
the other thing is that out of one end
or the other or both I tend to believe
it doesn't come out the same time out of
both but ends the favored one and then
the other but no one knows that for sure
a fountain or jet and a new constant of
motion has entered along the axis axial
momentum P the same momentum is flinging
a ball out into space own you do it
repeatedly many balls or many particles
or many something a flow out into space
which is the jet or fountain of these
great galaxies I wish I could tell you
what the substance was it's going out
there I don't know I'll say a little bit
about it but first to show you two
pictures which both come from worked out
the VLA by my colleague professor Dreier
just 10 feet in front of me there and
here's this beautiful picture with high
resolution and wonderful dynamic range
showing weak features that no one ever
saw before and just going
and these pools that we talked about
which are so nice to call pools well
they're not static pools homogeneous
objects at all the way they were drawn
on the red map that you saw they're full
of it Nantucket tracery heaven knows why
and there it is again
and who knows if we at bag to fight it
once more with good dynamic range if we
would not see helical threads develop
along I don't know just don't know let
me show you the next one which is even
more striking here's another radio
galaxy again seen the same high dynamic
range scheme and this one is throwing
out a beam which is itself generating
pretty surely puffs of some kind puffs
of relativistic particles capable making
radio there's one there's a bigger mix
one there's one here's the very clear
one at the end and look at this great
big one out there now what's going on
it's not easy to make a model for this
there are many tantalizing possibilities
some people see in it they sort of a
like real skyrockets an object has been
flying out there which itself explodes
or many of them which explode one after
another and give you these puffs maybe
it is some kind of internal collisions
can be made I'm not prepared to go
through the time and position sequence
to suggest which it is suffice it to say
nothing is very continuous what we know
this really remains a somewhat
mysterious but hard to argue away
picture and all we can say is we don't
know very much
what is it the fountain the jet that's
what I wanted to end by saying yes it is
hard to know what's going on there the
substance of the very jet itself is in
doubt I like to think it is sometimes
hydrogen plasma negative electrons and
positive protons sometimes perhaps mixed
together electron and positron pair
plasma I think we've never seen before
except an occasional particle or so on
the earth but capabie made in these
great central engines the Whirlpool in
the center where radiation and particles
are in strong relativistic interaction
we don't know we have to find that out
and maybe it throws up those bombs as
you know that are making themselves
explosions I hate to believe that but
it's been suggested
how to fling it ourselves years ago I
don't think it's real but we don't know
yet all we say is we don't know what the
Jets are I think that the theories which
exist abound are probably premature of
course there are very many of them I've
only selected a few they differ they
have broad characteristics in common but
many details differ and probably
everybody's still trying to have some
place of application that's the nature
of the subjects not a simple subject
description the way the world works and
not the way you can abstract to a single
particle in the laboratory so I can
close now and I will simply say that I
think we've demonstrated there are
fireworks out there that the fireworks
are foreshadowed but only faintly
foreshadowed in the comfortable domestic
universe that we once had I think we
have demonstrated pretty well the last
20 years that two universes are
commingled a domestic one and an alien
one we could not live in or near the
alien structures but we don't we
couldn't indeed do live and are adapted
to and nurtured by the spheres and the
discs of the uniform well behaved
gravitation of the Almanac it's the same
gravitation but we see it combed out and
tamed by history indeed when the world
was new it was heavily bombarded with
all kinds of chaotic bangs as the moon's
surface still shows today at a time when
the solar system too was a place of
chaos and randomness that we live among
order is the sign that we have lived
here not the demonstration that order is
everywhere yes order can come but it
requires an evolutionary sequence to
appear so that's it the domestic and the
alien both evolved and of the past I
talked a little bit with that last time
because my cosmos of the past was
extremely bland but it had very high
energy and that combination blandness
and high energy gave rise to the
complexity and the disorder order
combined that we see by looking around
but of course until you look far away
you won't find anything but
that which is suited to where you are
and this perhaps is one of the lessons I
wish that clearers could have said a
great deal more about this will be nice
mostly there try as I say trying to
follow I think the challenge for the
next for the rest of this century is to
try to put this kind of subject on a
footing similar to this 20 years that we
spent or 30 years more in getting the
theory of stellar evolution into some
kind of maturity that certain search
engine is not there now we do not really
know what we claim to have known about
the spheres and the disks we need much
more we have a very interesting
challenge placed before us primarily
experimental the ideas must come for
theorists they will come the Space
Telescope of 86 will be an important
contribution many other things will come
the wonderful improvement in technology
of measurement instrumentation the
clever physicists are inventing every
year is of course the clue to
understanding of the universe so I close
then with a reminder that back we are at
a tranquil world there are news and of
course this is the dome of the
observatory and this is where we think
we are in but we're only in portion of
it I am also mindful just to close
there's a little contradiction here
because I know in this dome there might
be a CCD and that CCD was not developed
by astronomers but in the service of
infrared monitoring from from high orbit
and I think that we will manage to
understand this extraordinary and
challenging universe if we can stay at
peace long enough so that the
experimenters and the theorists can work
out what is really there
you